Film Courage: Let’s talk about wounds and
fears of our main character.
How severe should they be?
If they’re too extreme, will they scare
the viewer away?
Michael Hauge: Well first of all keep in the
mind that the wound is something that always
occurs before the story actually begins.
It’s in the character’s backstory.
Rarely in a movie will we actually see that
wound.
The only reason we would see it is if there’s
a prologue that shows the wound.
So if you take a movie like TWISTER where
we see her father swept away by a tornado
and we flash forward to where she’s a grown
up but we know that’s a wounding experience
that is affecting her now.
Or it might be in a flashback.
HITCH is a good example of that.
I’m not really fond of flashbacks as a rule,
especially to reveal wounds but in that movie
it works I think because it’s such a funny
flashback as well as touching and establishes
such an important quality for the character
of Hitch because we see when he was in college
he had his heart broken and that’s where
he acquired the belief.
If I’m going to fall in love with anybody
it’s going to lead to a broken heart, which
leads to his identity which is I’ll help
everybody else fall in love but it’s not
for me.
So I think it’s more palatable if you will,
but I don’t think you’re going to scare
anybody away with it because oftentimes we
won't see it.
So keep in mind you’re not going to announce
the wound in most movies.
Sometimes we’re aware, like in SLEEPLESS
IN SEATTLE the opening shot is a man holding
his son’s hand over a grave saying “Mommy
died.”
That’s pretty direct.
Oftentimes we don’t learn what that wound
is until well into the story.
It’s well half way through GOODWILL HUNTING
before we find out about the abuse that he
suffered when he was a child or find out the
details about his father taking a belt to
him.
In GRAVITY, it doesn’t open by saying “I’m
sorry about your daughter dying.”
It comes out gradually after the opportunity
when the space debris comes through and destroys
the ship and so on.
Then Ryan (Dr. Ryan Stone) is talking to the
George Clooney character and revealing what
it was that happened back on earth that led
to her daughter dying and why she is carrying
that around with her.
So it’s not going to be abrupt.
It’s not going to be right at the top of
the story most of the time.
And last of all, the most effective ways to
reveal the wound is through dialogue.
It’s oftentimes more powerful to hear about
a wound that the character suffered than it
would be to actually watch it on the screen.
A great example of this is the movie LA CONFIDENTIAL.
By the way I just read the Curtis Hanson,
who co-wrote and directed the movie, just
passed away yesterday.
So this is the day we’re filming this thing
and I’m so sad because I think it is just
one of the great American movies and great
American screenplays.
But the wound for Bud White, the Russell Crowe
character is when he was a child he watched
his father beat mother to death with a tire
iron while he was chained to the bed and he
was left there with the body for two days.
That would be such an unbelievably gruesome
experience to watch on the screen.
It’s such a beautiful moment when he finally
reveals it because it’s right after the
mid-point.
He’s just made love to Lynn (Bracken) the
Kim Basinger character.
And it shows how they have gotten closer.
They are connected more at this level of essence.
Finally he’s opening up about exactly what
the pain is that he’s been carrying around
so long and what led to him kind of becoming
this brute cop who still does everything he
can to rescue women.
So I don’t think it’s something to worry
about in the way you’ve said.
I think it’s something to skillfully weave
into the story so that we’ll feel more affinity
to the character and it will lead to the character’s
identity.
Film Courage: You’re saying that we don’t
have to show the wound or explain what happened
but at some point we do reveal it?
Or are there some stories where we know they’re
wounded but it’s never totally revealed
what that wound is or how it happened?
Michael Hauge: Yes.
There are movies where it’s never clearly
stated.
TITANIC is that way.
It’s never clear what he identity is and
what he essence is.
She longs to be passionate.
She longs to live a fulfilled, passionate,
adventuresome life, but she’s stuck with
this mother who interfere in her life and
a rich guy who is really a jerk.
And so it never says “Well when I was a
child this happened.
Or when I was an adolescent this happened.
We can infer some things.
The inferences I make is probably she either
had no father or the father abandoned them
early on.
And her mother is so intent that she find
a rich guy to take care of her.
But it’s never really stated fully, so you
can go without revealing it as long as we
get a clear idea of the identity that has
resulted for the hero is.
The main thing that I think is you as the
novelist or you as the screenwriter need to
know what the wound is.
You need to know the backstory for your hero
well enough that you can say this is what
wounded them in the past and this is why they
are the way they are in the present.
Question for the Viewers: What other movies
came to mind while watching this clip?